- Well, welcome everybody to the first
of two Franke Visiting Fellows Lectures,
our opportunity to share with
the larger Yale Community,
Work in Progress by James McAuley tonight
and by Alejandra Oliva
on Thursday, April 21st.
the Franke Visiting
Fellows serve as catalysts
for intellectual gatherings at the
Whitney Humanities Center,
setting their own agendas
and presenting their
work to the community.
Their presence ensues
ongoing interdisciplinary
exchange and creative debate at the
Whitney in particular
and at Yale in general.
Franke Visiting Fellows
are an integral part
of the Whitney Humanities Center Fellowship.
And this year I've been
especially grateful
to James McAuley and Alejandra Oliva
for their supportive presence
in our Wednesday fellows forum.
The Franke Visiting
Fellows Program is made
possible by the generosity
of Richard and Barbara,
Franke, who have done so much for
the Whitney Humanity Center.
Tonight, I'm delighted to
introduce James McAuley,
whom we've come to know as Jake.
He graduated from Harvard with a degree
in History and Literature.
Awarded a Marshall Scholarship
in his senior year,
he went on to complete a PhD
in History at Oxford University
then served as Paris Correspondent
for the Washington Post
while he continued his
research in French history.
In 2021,
Jake published the
House of Fragile Things,
Jewish Art collectors
in the Fall of France,
just now awarded the
National Jewish Book Award.
It was all over Twitter.
(audience clapping)
Last night.
(laughing)
This gripping book,
really, gripping book takes us into
the world of the great
Jewish art collectors
of 20th century France,
describing their contribution
to a French nation
that ultimately betrayed
and destroyed them.
Next, Jake will publish a biography
of the Zion's philanthropist
Edmond Rothschild
in Yale University Press'
Jewish Live Series.
The work Jake has been doing here
at the Whitney widens his lens.
Black milk of Dawn will be an overarching
history of Holocaust memory reconsidered
at this crucial moment when
the last witnesses are dying.
he will show that there was never anything
automatic about naming or
remembering the Holocaust
and that denial and
revisionism have dogged
the efforts of historians
from the beginning.
This is a courageous
project for he's willing
to look at the cracks in the edifice of
Holocaust memory and to
interrogate its possible futures.
I should add that Jake
is one of my favorite
opinion writers,
( Jake laughing)
whether he's writing about the Demise of
the French Left in the
New York review of books,
calling Putin on his distortions in
the Washington Post or challenging
Alan Finkle Crowd on
cancel culture hysteria
on France Culture Radio.
Jake's exemplary engagement as historian
and critic shows that
understanding the past
can contribute to being a positive agent
for change in one's own time.
Please join me in welcoming Jake McCauley.
(audience clapping)
- Ah, well, thank you so much, Alice
for that very kind introduction.
And indeed for having
me here at the Whitney,
it has been just incredible
opportunity to read
and think and reflect these
past couple of months.
And I'm afraid you're
gonna have to prime me
out of the office when the clock runs out.
and thank you to all of our audience
members for joining tonight.
I really appreciate that.
And it has been just a pleasure more
than I can say to be here
and to begin the research for my next book
which Alice mentioned briefly
and which is tentatively titled
Black Milk of Dawn Jewish
Survival and Holocaust Memory.
I'm gonna talk with you
today about Salo Baron,
one of the principle
characters in that story,
a man whose personal journey
I find immensely inspiring
and whose historical
writings I find compelling,
confusing and from time
to time frustrating,
sort of all at once.
And I should say that, you know,
I have my background in French history
and the are sort of new readings for me.
And I'm well aware that
many of our esteemed guests
in the audience tonight
are far more well versed
than I am in Baron and all of his work.
So, please let me know
if I get anything wrong
and I welcome any feedback
you may have at the end.
But first of all,
a brief bit of biography
on Baron whose student
Yosef Hayim later called
him the greatest...
Sorry, this is Baron himself,
whose students Yosef
Hayim later called him
the greatest Jewish historian
of the 20th century.
A title I don't think
anyone has ever disputed.
And that I myself will certainly
not be disputing tonight.
Indeed Baron who spent
his entire career laboring
over his 18 volume social
and religious history
of the Jews was the 20th Century's answer
to the likes of Simon
Dubnow and Henrich Graetz
from the 19th century.
Like Dubnows, Velt
Gistictor and (indistinct)
Baron's social and religious history
was an attempt by one man to write
the entire course of Jewish history,
a monumental task if ever there were one.
And this was truly his life's work.
He began the project as a young scholar
and constantly expanding the volume until
just before his death in 1989.
And these of course are Baron's,
Antacede, Greats and Dubnow.
So to continue,
Baron was born into a wealthy family
in Tarno Alisia, which
is in present day Poland.
His father was a banker
and was also the president
of the town's Jewish community.
And it was a population of roughly 16,000
according to available
estimates that we have.
By all accounts,
the young Baron was already a polymath.
In keeping with the style
of local Jewish elites
at the time he could
say the Polish, Yiddish,
biblical and modern
Hebrew, French and German
and his students among whom ranked some
of the greatest Jewish
historians of the 20th century,
Yori Shalmy whom I've already mentioned,
but also Arthur Hertzberg,
the list goes on and on,
Would recall his ability to lecture
without notes and at least five languages.
And here I am lecturing with notes in
my own native language.
So, I mean, it's quite impressive.
In any case Baron received rabbinical
ordination at the Jewish
Theological Seminary
in Vienna in the early 1920s
and earned no fewer than three doctorates
from the University of Vienna all by 1923.
He began his teaching career at
the Jewish Teachers
College in Vienna whereby
Stepen Wise persuaded
him to move to New York
to teach at the Jewish
Institute of Religion there,
which he did by the end of the decade.
And of course it was there in New York
that he was poached by Columbia University
a few short years later,
where he became the first
to teach Jewish history
as a historical discipline
in the American University.
And there's been much written about that
including a recent volume
by many leading scholars
in the field celebrating his contribution
to Jewish studies in the
American University specifically.
But just a little bit more about
his attachment to Columbia.
In May 1928,
Linda Miller of New Rochelle New York sent
a letter to Nicholas Butler who was then
the president of Columbia,
informing him of her desire to establish
an endowed chair in Jewish history
and honor of her late husband who had died
about six months before.
And by the way,
this is a picture from
the Columbia archives
of the University in the twenties,
sort of around the time
when he would've arrived.
And all the letters between Linda Miller
and Butler in the Columbia archives
and Miller's vision for this
new teaching role is
quite revealing, I think.
And I quote, "I should
like to make it clear
that it is the spiritual
and intellectual aspects
of Jewish life that I should hope to
see accentuated in the courses rather
than the nationalistic
ideas which have recently
become popular in some quarters."
She wrote to the University President.
Eventually the search landed on Baron,
although not without its
share of drama as usual.
And he took up his post
in 1930 and he was on
the upper west side until
his retirement in 1963.
By the time he arrived
at Columbia, of course,
Baron was already well
known for an article
that is still an essential reference
for all students of Jewish studies.
And which sadly seems to
be the only piece of his
work that is still widely read today.
This as many of you may guess,
is the essay entitled
Ghetto in Emancipation,
his famous 1928 argument
against the so-called
Laquamores conception
of Jewish history before
emancipation in the French revolution.
This was a hugely
influential intervention.
And it's this argument that would inform
the rest of his long and prolific career.
And I quote, "Surely Baron
wrote in the last line
of that piece it is time break with the
Laquamore Theory of Pre Revolutionary War
and to adopt a view more in a
accord with historical truth."
I should also note that in that volume,
I mentioned recently published in
honor of Baron's legacy,
there's a masterful
examination of that essay
and its themes by none other
than Yale's own David Sorkin.
But in general,
Baron was skeptical of the view
that saw emancipation as the solution
to the Jewish problem in Europe.
And he argued Contra,
Graetz and others that
and I quote,
" There was no complete contrast between
the black of the middle ages and the white
of the post emancipation period."
What mattered for Baron
was that Jewish history
was not to be understood
as a teleology of tragedy
or as a saga of suffering.
But Baron could scarcely have imagined
or anticipated the brutal
century into which he was born.
One that was certainly the most Laquamore
of any in the entire Jewish experience.
And this is by the way,
a photograph of Baron's
hometown Tarno from
the US Holocaust Memorial with the...
It captures sort of
(indistinct) persecutions
of the actual community that he came from.
So, although he had left
Europe years before,
the Holocaust was more than a rupture in
his understanding of Jewish
history and its evolution.
It was a deeply personal rupture as well.
And this I think is a
significantly underappreciated
aspect of his own story and scholarship.
Most of his family that
had remained in Europe,
including his parents and
his sister were murdered.
but even still he continued
with his argument against
the Laquamore theory
insisting that Jewish history
could not be allowed to become a history
of persecution alone,
but that it was a history
of the intellectual,
cultural and even spiritual responses that
the Jews had faced as a people
throughout their long history.
Baron found solace in the promise
and the reality of Jewish survival,
at least as he understood it.
in my reading so far,
and there are so many of them
when it comes to Salo Baron.
Among the most poignant
has been the conclusion
of volume three of Baron's first draft
of a social and religious
history of the Jews.
Which was published by Columbia
university Press in 1937.
So, after Hitler's rise to power,
after the Nuremberg Laws but before
the full extent of Nazi
barbarity was clear.
At the end of the shorter although still
three volume version of the book
that would later become
Baron's Magnum Opus,
he acknowledges the concern.
He correctly assumed would
be on his reader's minds.
Would the Jewish people withstand
the Nazi menace gaining
traction by the day?
He was adamant in his response.
And he insisted that
the answer was already
clear in the course of the history he
had told in the approximately thousand
pages up to that point.
And here I quote,
"The answer to the searching question
of our time is evidently given."
He wrote,
"The Jewish people and
their religion are going
to survive the present
extraordinary crisis."
And he under underscored are going.
He quoted the book of Isaiah
and called on Jewish leaders to quote,
"Sing unto the Lord, a
new song, a song that
rebuilt Jewish life through culture
and education as a value
worthy of affirmation."
But this was before the final solution,
a catastrophe that would
touch Baron personally
and professionally
because the man who argued
so powerfully that Jewish history
itself was a form of
solace and a blueprint
for regeneration in of itself was suddenly
confronted with the question of memory.
specifically what to
remember about the Holocaust,
which in Baron's time did
not yet even have a name.
How much weight was
this unspeakable event?
Which Baron initially
called the Great Catastrophe
to be given in the long
degree of Jewish history.
The likes of which he wrote over
the course of his entire career.
And most importantly,
did it represent the reputation of
the Anti Laquamore
convictions once and for all.
In my talk today,
I'm going to examine Baron,
not so much as his historian
but as a historical actor himself.
As someone involved intimately with
the construction of Holocaust
memory in two key moments.
First in Offenbach after the war with
the Jewish Cultural Reconstruction Project
and then at the Eichmann Trial,
where he was a star witness
for the prosecution.
In Zahor, the classic 1982 treaties
on Jewish History versus
Jewish Memory written
by Baron's student Yori Shalmy.
We are asked the following
question in the introduction,
and here I quote Yori Shalmy,
"But what were the Jews to
remember and by what means?
Baron himself had his answers and his life
and his career were a
sort of explanation."
So to begin with Offenbach after the war,
before the end of the Second World War,
the American Jewish Conference
published a pamphlet
entitled Program for Post-War
Jewish Reconstruction,
calling for an end to antisemitism,
aid for surviving European Jews,
a war crimes tribunal
and restitution of stolen property.
It was Baron who wrote this pamphlet
and it was significant that he used
the word reconstruction.
This was very much the view
of American Jewish
Organizations in those days,
unable to process in the
sort of minor detail,
the unfolding disaster
in its full totality
and therefore,
focusing on the on what was to come after
the war which had yet to arrive.
Baron was seemingly incapable at that time
of grasping the extent of
the ongoing persecutions
in Europe, not to mention
their intensification.
Like many other Jewish
scholars of his time
especially in the United States
he assumed that the Jews
would survive Nazism
as they had survived other pogroms
and expulsions in the past.
In 1940 Baron wrote the following,
Reflecting on the Nature of Europe's
Multinational Empires that he so valued.
It has been an old historic and this is
(mumbles)
And I quote,
"It has been an old historic experience
that the Jews suffered more heavily
and purely national states than
in countries of multiple nationality.
Germany's nationalistic
spirit draws the country
irresistibly into military adventures.
Should it win and conquer
large territories,
it would lose its national homogeneity
and become a state of
multiple nationality which
incidentally might cool
its anti semitic zest."
So that's Baron in 1940.
Eventually Baronn and
others confronted were
confronted with the
extent of the destruction
and the devastation including the loss
of his two parents and one of his sisters.
He would later recall that turnoff,
which had about 20,000 Jews before the war
had only about 20 when he
next visited in the 1950s.
And yet despite his
immense personal trauma
and profound loss,
he refused to alter his view of either
the Jewish past and certainly
not the Jewish present.
He threw himself into aiding
survivors however he could,
but as an architect of postwar memory
his view seems to have been...
Or one of the architects I
should say of postwar memory.
His view seems to have
been that what was most
important to remember was the richness
of the civilization that once was.
Not so much the evil mechanics
of the destruction itself.
Baron soon headed what was called
the Jewish Cultural Reconstruction,
which was a task force sponsored by
the US government in
April, 1947 to collect
and distribute airless Jewish property in
the American occupied zone
of Germany after World War II.
So based in Offenbach.
Those who worked with
Baron in that project
were fellow future arbiter
of Holocaust Memory.
Not all of whom agreed with him.
I I should note, Hannah Arendt especially
but also Lucy Dawidowicz
and Gershom Scholem were all in some ways
involved with this postwar
restitution project.
So the archives in
Washington DC have many of
the materials pertaining
to this task force.
This is one of them
here is Hannah Arendt .
One of Baron's sort of
his deputy and colleagues
in that major undertaking
And here is Lucy Dawidowicz
as a young student.
Let's see.
Through Jewish Cultural Reconstruction,
Baron was building a Holocaust Memory
that was based on his image of the Jewish
people's enduring strength
and above all else will to survive.
He by no means ignored the extent
of the catastrophe in Europe.
A catastrophe that had as we've mentioned,
had claimed members of his own family,
but he was nevertheless
invested in designing
and advocating a means of
continuation by whatever means.
And here I turned to the historian,
Barbara Kirsten, black gimblet,
who has written that Baron insisted
that there were two essential elements
in what she calls Jewish continuity.
That is first, maintained
commitment to tradition.
And second, the enduring
ties of Jewish community.
So in 1945, before the war had even ended,
Baron was still expressing
these hopes however
fanciable they may seem to us now.
And here I quote,
"Religious history has given us evidence
of how deeply humanity may sink
and still rise again to
high spiritual levels.
It is not unreasonable to hope that out of
the depths of misery and despair,
some new saving forms of belief
and observance may
arise which will provide
an answer to the perplexities
of our Jewish experience."
As the historian
Elizabeth Goluch has noted
in her brilliant recent study,
A Mortuary of Books,
Baron's general idea was at salvaging
the material remains of
the Jewish civilization
that had been, would
keep future generations
building on those traditions of the past
and furthering Jewish
knowledge in the present.
as Goluch writes,
his efforts to salvage
cultural property fit with
the notion in every respect symbolizing
the potential to secure
and preserve past worlds,
their knowledge and traditions.
When he was asked to sum
up the work of the JCR,
this organization in 1955,
Baron underscored all of those themes.
And he wrote,
"The Jewish people succeeded in salvaging
500,000 volumes, 1200 scrolls of law,
7,000 artistic and ceremonial objects."
He wrote. "Far beyond
their monetary value.
These collections symbolize the continuity
of the heritage of the Jewish people."
In a letter he sent to
the State Department,
the objects he and his
team were able to recover,
especially the books were
the material manifestations
of the legacy he sought to reconstruct.
He wrote that books have always been
the very lifeblood of
the people of the book.
Which shows that for him books were a kind
of representation of the
Jewish people as a whole.
To save their orphan
books was thus to preserve
what mattered most about the Jews
as a civilization and a culture.
And this, as you can see,
this is a photo of some
of the books that were
recovered in that sort
of Offenbach Initiative.
And now to look at the
Eichmann Trial a little bit
and Baron's testimony at that moment.
So the next moment,
when he was a major actor in the emergence
of Holocaust memory was the Eichmann Trial,
which needs no introduction.
It's unclear if Baron ever knew he wasn't
the Israeli government's first choice as
the prosecution star witness.
They had wanted the Historian and Juris,
Jacob Robinson who served
as a Special Advisor
on Jewish affairs at the
Nuremberg trials to Israel
and also to Israel at the United Nations.
Most famously Robinson would write
the Blistering Rebuttal to Hannah Arendt,
Eichmann in Jerusalem,
a book entitled,
And the Crooked Shall be Made Straight.
But the Israeli consulate
in New York reached Baron
on the upper west side regardless,
inviting him to participate
in what was certainly
among the most important events in
the postwar attempt to establish
a durable memory of the Holocaust.
The significance of the Eichmann Trial
in the history of Holocaust memory
is impossible to understate.
The dramatic arrest and
extradition of Adolph Eichmann
from Argentina sedated and dressed
in an LL flight attendants
uniform now captured
in various popular films
and novels that I'm sure
many of us have seen,
was not just an attempt by the young state
of Israel to establish
itself on the world stage.
Although it was certainly
a watershed moment
in the country's history.
In the words of the historian Tom Segev,
once Ben Gurion solemnly announced that
the government had Eichmann in custody.
And I quote,
"Israelis had not known
since the declaration
of independence, so deep a
sense of national unity."
But the trial was more than a mural
illustration of national strength.
It was a deliberate
attempt to show the world
just what had befallen the
Jewish people as a whole
little more than a decade before.
And here I quote the
famous first paragraph
of the Chief Prosecutor, Gideon Hausner,
who is on the left right there.
He gave a 10 hour speech at the trial.
And this is the first paragraph of
his kind of quite amazing speech.
"When I stand before you
hear judges of Israel
to lead the prosecution of Adolph Eichmann,
I am not standing alone.
With me are 6 million accusers,
but they cannot rise to their feet
and point an accusing finger towards him
who sits in the dock and cry.
I accuse for their ashes are piled up high
on the Hills of Auschwitz
and the fields of Treblinka,
and are strew in the forest of Poland.
Their graves are scattered
throughout the length
and breadth of Europe.
Their blood cries out
but their voice is not heard.
Therefore I will be their
spokesman and in their
name I will unfold the
terrible indictment.
Visibility was paramount
to that indictment.
Journalists from around the
world covered the trial.
As we all know, Hannah Arendt
but also Ellie Wiesel
and Hugh Trevor-Roper
from Britain among others.
Most importantly, as many of you know,
this was the first trial
ever to be recorded
for television as only select portions
of the postwar Nuremberg
trials were filmed.
But a television network recorded
the daily proceedings
which were then flown out
every night to the Europe and the US,
quite the undertaking for 1961.
But this was the point
of the entire exercise
as Gideon Hausner would later recall.
The idea was that the
whole world could watch.
Baron took his assignment of being
the historical consciousness of these
6 million absent accusers
extremely seriously.
His student,
the great historian in
Rabbi Arthur Hertzberg
later recalled that he had never seen
his professor as anxious as he was during
this final preparations for the trial.
And the Israeli government
had made his assignment clear.
In order to convict Eichmann forcefully,
in order to demonstrate the full extent
of his brutality and his evil,
the prosecution needed
to show the significance
of what the Nazi's had done
and just what exactly they had destroyed.
In advance of the trial,
Hausner and this I borrow
from Deborah Lipstadt's
book on the trial,
Hausner had written to
Baron that it was important
to prove the Nazi intention
to annihilate the Jewish people.
And it is therefore vital for the trial
to present documentation that will expose
the national and cultural
value of the Jewish Centers
that were destroyed and Holocaust.
When Baron arrived in
Israel in late March, 1961,
he had an audience with none
other than Ben Gurion himself.
And of course that is Ben Gurion.
We don't know exactly
how the conversation went
but we do have what Ben
Gurion wrote in his diary
after the encounter.
Which was that and I quote it,
"It is important to
make clear to our youth
the magnitude of the
qualitative loss resulting
from the extermination of 6 million
and therefore describe
the spiritual character
of the jewelry that was exterminated.
Present outstanding
personalities, like Einstein,
Bialik, Dubnow et cetera."
And the historian Deborah Lipstadt,
whom I just mentioned,
has in that same book that Ben Gurion
and Hausner were deeply
anxious that Baron,
a professor would come across as boring.
And Hausner actually
tried to tell the renowned
scholar from Columbia
University to make sure
his remarks were engaging,.
Which did not go over well.
Boredom as Baron said,
"Boredom is relative
and very often depends on the manner
in which the facts are presented."
He snapped back.
"Anyway nothing was more
boring than the testimony
of the Yard Vashim
representative regarding
the validity of
certificates and documents.
And yet you accepted this testimony
as being essential to the trial."
Hausner let it go.
"You will of course express your opinions
on historical issues as you see fit,"
he assured the visiting professor.
Your unique scientific standing
and your publications
are sufficient guarantee
that the picture you present
will be accurate and enthralling.
When Baron finally
entered the witness box,
about two weeks into the trial,
the judge asked him to put on the keeper
and to take the oath.
He obliged but then quickly
took off the keeper,
apologizing for his imperfect Hebrew
and delivering what was in many ways
one of the most important
speeches he ever gave.
Baron's testimony was lengthy
but certain parts of it show how he tried
to preserve his anti Laquamore
conception by presenting
the Nazi menace as
something that was entirely
separate and distinct
from previous pogroms
or anti-Jewish persecutions.
And this is Baron in the witness box.
The attempt to see
Auschwitz as the culmination
of the long history of
antisemitism he suggested
entirely missed the point.
And I quote,
"Such assertions malign the middle ages."
He said while on the stand,
"Although there has been
immemorial antisemitism,
it is well to remember
that there was practically
no violence accompanied
by blood shed under
the Persians of the Greeks.
There were minor outbreaks
in the days of Philo of Alexandria.
There were no pogroms under the Muslims."
But in keeping with both
his earlier scholarship
and his work in Offenbach salvaging
the remnants of Jewish culture,
Baron also used his testimony to offer
most of all an impassioned
defense of the diaspora
and that it had achieved.
And here I quote a passage
from his own remarks.
"As a permanent minority
for some 2000 years,
Jews were forced to seek
the kinds of openings
that were available to newcomers.
When they found and
used such opportunities,
they were working for
both their own benefit
and that society as a whole.
I have long believed that
much of Jewish history
ought to be rewritten in terms of
the pioneering services
which the Jews were forced
to render by the particular
circumstances of their history."
And he continued,
"With courage and perseverance,
the Jewish people tried to adjust
the new situation not merely passively,
but independently and creatively.
Accustomed through the long history
of their dispersion to
such creative adjustments,
they were able to develop
during the interwar period,
certain new forms of
communal and cultural living,
which factified Jewish
life throughout the world,
contributed significantly
to human civilization
and held out great promise for the future.
All this was cut short
by the Nazi attack,
unprecedented in scope,
geographic extension
and murderous intensity.
And in another moment in his remarks,
he said the following,
"Of course,
the Jewish people also had
its sinners and idiots,
thieves and lunatics, but on balance,
future historians are likely to call
the first third of the 20th century,
the golden age of
AshkeNatziv Jewry in Europe,
just as they will see in it
the beginning of a modern
Sotheby's Renaissance.
The Israelis were upset
with this testimony.
Again, we have mostly just Ben Gurion's,
which was unsparing in
its criticism of Baron.
"Just as I feared," Ben Urian wrote,
"We had failed miserably."
Adding that, "Baron
embarrassed us deeply."
The precise reasons for
that opinion are unclear
but the historian Hanna
Yablonka has suggested
that it was likely that
Baron had merely contradicted
what was becoming the
official Israeli narrative
about the Holocaust.
Namely that it had marked the end
of European Jewish civilization,
which had been doomed
for centuries anyway.
But Baron's convictions
could not be shaken.
In conclusion,
I think it's worth
revisiting Baron's conception
of Jewish survival as he aged.
So in 1963, the year
retirement from Columbia,
he published an essay entitled
Newer Emphasis in Jewish History.
which was a revision of an earlier essay.
He had written on the
same topic years before.
And this is a text in
which he revisited his
criticism of the Laquamore
conception of Jewish history.
"All my life." He wrote,
"I have been struggling against the Hitler
two dominant Laquamore
conception of Jewish history,
a term which I have been
using for more than 40 years.
Because I have felt that an over-emphasis
on Jewish sufferings
distorted the total picture
of the Jewish historic evolution
and at the same time
badly served a generation
which had become impatient
with the nightmare
of endless persecutions and massacres."
That line is often cited
but what follows is not,
which is Baron actively grappling with
the extent of the Holocaust devastation.
Insisting that and I quote,
"We must not misunderstand
the true realities
of life and psychology among those who had
endured the recent catastrophe including
the inherent tragedies
of Jewish life during
the two millennia of the dispersion."
This I think points to
an important dimension
of his opposition to the
Laquamore Theory as he aged.
It comes across as though he doesn't
have a firm answer anymore.
And that perhaps the anti
Laquamore critique was never meant
as an explanation for everything
that could be applied at will.
As we've seen,
it was an active choice that was
neither self evident nor inevitable.
And one with whom many
others certainly disagreed.
Although today it has gained
quite a dominant position.
But perhaps most of all,
for someone who had lost so much,
this way of writing and thinking
the Jewish past was
itself a form of survival.
Not collective survival
but personal survival.
And that is the conclusion of my talk.
(audience clapping)
- Thanks, Jake.
We'll take some questions.
- Yes, with pleasure.
- Thank you, Mc.
Thank you. That was very moving.
Can you say something
about his wife, Jean?
I believe (mumbles)
- Jeannette.
- Jeannette yeah.
My recollection is that she was a sort
of full-time secretary---
- Absolutely.
And research assistant
but never appeared on
the title page any of his words.
- Absolutely.
I believe his wife was
absolutely influential
on his work and more
than just as a secretary,
as a real collaborator and in many ways
a social and religious history of the Jews
is work that they did together.
And you're right.
That she does not appear on the title page
of the books but it's...
From everything we know about how the book
was produced and how it was written,
especially as it was
revised in later edition,
she was hugely,
hugely influential on
how it was put together.
- Thank you for that Jake.
Could you say something
about what motivated
you to take on this project?
- Oh, well (laughs)how
much time do we have.
(audience laughing)
I guess I've been interested
in these questions
for a very long time particularly
as an American Jew who grew up.
I was born in 1989,
sort of right before the
fall of the Berlin wall
in which at no point in my education was
the Holocaust not a kind
of major cornerstone.
So, you know,
that had a history,
that had a whole sort
of literature behind it.
And I just became very
interested as indeed
so many others have in how we arrived
at this conception that we
know so much about today,
which is the Holocaust.
Which might have assumed and
did assume different forms
and different cultural contexts.
And so looking at the
immediate postwar with
these characters, with these sort
of active debates raging in that time was
very interesting to me to
see sort of the choices
that were made and how we came to remember
what we came to remember
and like how they emerge as they did
but also what might have been.
Because there were,
as we all know, many other paths,
whole memory project could have taken.
And so I find it quite interesting
how it did evolve as it has.
- Thank you.
And that was a wonderful talk.
I'm really compelled by
your approach of thinking
of him as a historical actor
and not just a historian.
I would just love to hear
you speak more about that.
How that methodology came up for you.
- Yeah.
- 'Coz I just find it really compelling.
- Ah, well.
Thank you so much for that question.
I'm not sure it's super
complicated or anything.
I mean, it struck me that
in the aftermath of the war,
you have not just Baron but so many others
like Hanna Arendt, Lucy
Dawidowicz, the list goes on.
These were all the first and
like Raul, Hillberg, et cetera.
These were all the first major
historians of the Holocaust.
I mean,
Baron not so much the
historian of the Holocaust
but you know,
major Jewish historians
of the time grappling
with the Holocaust, I should say.
And were these amazing and Baron's case,
just tremendously prolific scholars
but they were more than that.
They were, they were
active participants in...
I mean many of them like Baron had had
the experience of having family killed.
Arendt herself as a refugee.
Dawidowicz had been in
Vilnius before the war
and had come back to
Europe to do this part.
So they were not just sort
of observers of the events.
The events had shaped all
of their lives intimately.
And I just think it's a
mistake not to consider
both at the same time and to consider
the scholarship in some
senses as an expression
of the personal journeys
that so many of them had.
Because in a way that was these sort
of emotional drive behind so much of it
or so it seems to me.
- Thank you for that.
- Yeah.
- Thank you, Jake.
That was elegant analysis of Salo Baron.
In terms of the impact of
the Holocaust on Baron.
I think that the whole
question of legal status
and guarantee of rights,
it was central for him.
after all Baron was
stateless for over 10 years.
It was only when Wise invited him to come
to New York to the Jewish
Institute of Religion
that Wise was able to
flex his muscles with
the state department
and to get Baron a Visa
and US citizenship.
But in his later. in his
essays from the 1960s,
which I think reflected his own experience
of statelessness with the collapse of
the a Austria-Hungarian monarchy,
he wrote about the insufficiency
of the nation state
as guaranteeing the rights of Jews
and other minorities and looked forward to
there being some kind of organization.
Of course the United Nations existed,
the League of Nations had failed at that,
but some kind of
international organization
which would which would
guarantee basic rights.
So, you know,
I'm wondering if you could
just comment on that.
- Yeah.
I mean, I think that's certainly...
I mean, again, you know,
this way, way better than I do.
So, that's absolutely
something I will think
more about as I continue my research.
But that in terms of what
at least I have thought
about so far,
I think you absolutely to get that sense
in what he wrote about Nazism
sort of even at the time.
I even quote one of the
passages where he says
that it is this sort of national character
of the enterprise that's
so hostile to the Jews.
And in fact,
if Nazi Germany had become
this sort of empire of sorts,
that was multinational,
multilingual, et cetera
then perhaps things might have been wise.
So I think you're absolutely right.
I mean,
as for what he imagined in
the long term in the postwar,
I don't know as much, but I don't know.
I, I think the emphasis on these kind
of supernational
organizations would put him in
the context of many other
thinkers of his time.
So, I mean,
it's not necessarily unique in that regard
but that's a really good
point to examine further.
- Thank you.
This has been enjoyable and moving
and I wanna ask you whether there's...
It felt like there was
an intimation of a kind
of anti-Jewish nationalist trajectory.
First from the letters
creating Baron's post
and then in kind of his conflict explicit
or implicit with Ben Gurion at the trial.
And I'm (indistinct) you've
made kind of no reference
to how the creation of state of Israel did
or didn't shape bar picture.
And I'm not asking you to speak
to kind of the present but
in terms of thinking about,
is this emphasis on spiritual status,
which he's how he
referred to European jury,
a kind of a consistent through line
that did in fact place him at odds with
a more political or nationalist
orientation towards Jewishness.
- So that is an excellent question.
And I'm very glad you raised that.
I think if I had more time,
I would've sort of delved
into that aspect of his work.
So, but first of all,
you know, Baron was a Zionist, absolutely.
I think the perceived conflict,
which I'm not sure was an actual conflict
with Ben Gurion at the
end was perhaps over
what kind of Zionism them each imagine.
So I don't think that
Baron was in any way,
anything but supportive
of the establishment.
I mean, he had visited
several times before Eichmann.
It wasn't something that
he opposed by any means
and he was a sort of
outspoken supporter of it.
I just think that he did
not necessarily agree
with the I guess official
narrative at the time,
which was to sort of
disparage the diaspora
as worthless, as doomed to fail,
as something that is nothing but
the anti chamber to Auschwitz.
And I think that that was the disagreement
if ever there were one.
I mean he was absolutely
a Zionist for sure.
- Can I get a second?
- Correct.
(laughing)
- Yeah, of course.
- You allude to him.
And I think this follows
up on the previous question
and that is there seems to be a narrative
that could be spelled out
in terms of his relation
to Schlom to towering--
- Yes.
- Intellectual academics but
are very different sorts.
And, and of course...
- And on and on--
- Schlom was also involved in reclamation
of books from after the Holocaust.
So in some ways there are
unparallel path switch.
- Absolutely.
- Don't don't intersect or maybe intersect
more than we've been able to see.
- I mean,
I think one of the things
that's been so interesting
for me about this whole project is just
the sort of interpersonal
relationships among,
as you say,
so many of these towering
figures that we all know
such as Schlom, Baron,
but also Hannah Arendt.
I was fascinated to learn that...
I think Baron shared in
the criticism of Eichman
and Jerusalem but ultimately
was very close with RN.
I mean, in fact,
I believe it was the Baron's who were
in Hannah Arendt's apartment when she died
and who called the ambulance
ones to collect her.
So there was this sort of intimacy among
this whole generation that went through
these events together
even if they disagreed.
So, one of the things I'm
hoping to do in the book
is to tease out as much as possible
some of those personal
relationships that stitch
these characters together because I think
it's quite illuminating and
it shows the way that the...
Well, I mean,
as we all know from people who live in
the real world but disagreements
between brilliant people are not always
intellectual in nature.
That there were sort of petty personal
elements of it as well.
And I think that that's equally important
in understanding how these ideas
and how these arguments
get mobilized and defended.
So I absolutely agree.
- Jake,
this was just really so fascinating
and obviously is just
in part of what you're
gonna be creating in this next book.
Can you give us a preview of, I mean,
you have just started to give us a preview
of the other aspects
that you're gonna break
the other people and the other aspects.
Can you fill that out even more?
I obviously this is.
- Sure.
- Early on, I'm just curious.
- It's sort of being planned as we speak
but basically I have several characters,
one of which is Baron
but also Hannah Arendt,
Lucy Dawidowicz, Raul Hilberg
and Elie Wiesel for the moment.
And looking at the...
I mean, I should say, as we all know,
it is an enormous huge amount of material
but the way that I'm
trying to sort of find
my way through is to follow the characters
at moments when they all reappear.
And again, as I mentioned
they all knew each other
and were largely in contact in many cases
for their entire lives.
So one of those moments would be Offenbach
when so many of the
characters work together.
Another is the Eichmann Trial when a lot of
them have cameo appearances
in different ways.
And then again, in New York, in the 1970s,
when so many are kind of
debating like Lucy Dawidowicz
and Hilberg for instance, the
meaning of it all.
And so that's how I've structured it.
And that it will come
together but we shall see.
- Really. I had a very similar question.
Yeah.
But an angle on the
question, which you know,
you were talking about the
construction of a memory.
So I wonder when does it begin for you?
And I guess that's a
question of imagination.
- When does what begin?
- The memory of the Holocaust?
- Yeah.
- When does it begin
or when does the story
that you're telling begin?
- Yeah.
- That is another excellent question.
I think the question of when it begins has
to be before the war is even over.
Absolutely.
And I think that there are
several important examples,
but one of them would be with the story
of Emmanuel Ringelblum
and the Warsaw Ghetto
sort of actively collecting trace of
the destruction while it was happening
and shoving them underground to make sure
that someone someday,
somehow would find them and know.
Now, that's not necessarily telling people
what the memory should be
and arbitrating the shape
and contours of it,
but it is providing raw
sort of primary sources
if you will for someone
else to construct it.
But it does show a consciousness of
the world historical significance of
the event while it was
unfolding and the imperative
to have some basis to remember it.
So I would say it definitely begins
while the war is still raging.
But then also I think
some of the most important
postwar beginnings of the memory question
were the question of names, right?
And I mentioned that
at the very beginning,
like for scholars like Baron,
what Baron initially called
the great catastrophe,
had no official name.
You know, many used
different names describe it.
And what's fascinating to observe
and to look at is the evolution of each of
the terms offered to
describe what we now call
the Holocaust in English but
which is called the Showa
and Hebrew and French.
How the terms emerged,
what their antecedence were,
what kind of implications
they gave the event
and how it shaped public
understandings of them.
So, I think that that's probably
the next really crucial step. Yeah.
(indistinct)
Alright.
- Continue informally but
before that (indistinct)
- Well, thank you all for coming.
(audience clapping)
So much.